el tribunal constitucional de Rusia ha
aprobado la anexión de cuatro
territorios ucranianos que están ahora
parcialmente ocupados por Rusia se trata
de la República popular detonía la
República Popular de lugans y también
los territorios de jerson y ahora
corresponde a la duma la cámara baja del
parlamento ruso aprobar esta anexión en
su sesión del lunes aunque se trata de
una anexión que ya ha sido rubricada por
el presidente ruso Vladimir Putin el
pasado viernes en un acto multitudinario
en el kreming en el que estuvo
acompañado de los líderes de estas
cuatro regiones Ahora hay mucha
incertidumbre sobre lo que va a ocurrir
a continuación porque se trata de unas
fronteras borrosas y lo hemos visto este
fin de semana porque con el avance de
nuevo de las tropas ucranianas en la
Ciudad de Lima una ciudad ucraniana
ocupada por Rusia hasta hace poco y que
ha pasado de pertenecer a la federación
rusa legalmente a todos los efectos este
fin de semana a volver a estar a todos
los efectos incluso efectos prácticos en
manos ucranianas lo mismo puede en la
región de jerson que está abajo fuerte
presión del fuego ucraniano en estos
últimos días